[Music]
well it's pandemonium right now there's
a lot of people here and a lot of cool
cars this is my 458 Italia custom made
with this really cool body kit I think
from the weather from Asia yeah
custom made West Coast Customs designed
it one of a kind I've had it for roughly
two years two years now um and it was my
first Ferrari
and I have to say goodbye to my baby is
that good enough for you that was like a
lot of being fair I'm gonna leave a pair
of my old Calvin's in there how many
cars have we done crazy
yeah so we start with the Range Rover
which is the first line ever
ooh smart bar the
ah
the range of our car your mom's car yeah
we did
we got the Batmobile the Batmobile and
then your - battle - yep
the Lincoln yeah
[Music]
not a lot is it working where the keys
at what's next with me I'm going back on
tour about February 14
all right so this is one of Justin's
first cars that we really did a whole
lot to it's a Ferrari 458 know so one of
the issues that we found was a Carfax on
it where there says there was some
damage but the damage actually was from
paparazzi that was chasing Justin a
little too close and we got a new bumper
so we're good so a 325 325
holding it all in hi 325 pay 3 3 10 20
hey 310 320 a 310 20 pony pony not a
mitigator 340 pound on a green on a pony
Henderson upper-hand in here Justin so
uh along with the car we're going to get
an exclusive pair of tickets to one of
my United States shows so we're gonna
add that in there I go back on tour
February 15 so uh yeah keep going there
we go
57 you just pay 400 pounds in on it out
of it get out Justin you want 400 hey
400,000 on it hey 400,000 out of
justinian Jimmy which one we got a 395
with Jimmy now 400 pounds headed hey 395
to get up a hundred thousand
[Music]
so three hundred and ninety five
thousand dollars muscle lounge thank you
[Applause]
you